σίγορα υπάρχει αυτό το χρημα και το δγνουμε ησίγουρα υπάρχει να μαξιλαράκι είναι πλέο να
σματική προοπολογισμί και είναι πάρα πολι θετικό και πρέπει να παραμείνουν πλεώ να σματικοή προεπολογισμ
και και θεωρώ ότι με την ανάρτυξη ης κυπριακής οικονομίας και τν μια να νοικοκύρεμα
που έχει γίνει μπορώ η και η κυβέρτηση να να κάνει πιο καλή κοινωνική πολιτική
μέσω επιδομάτο όμως τα επιδόματα πάντα λέω εγώ είναι παυσήπονα είναι δεν είναι αρνητικό αλλά
δεν είναι λύση δεν θα αλλάξει ζωή κάποιου με πενήνται εκατό διακόσια ευρώ είναι καλώ
να δείδονται στο χευμένα όχι οριζόντια και να βλέπουμε όμως πως μπορούμε να αναπτύξουμε να
μεγαλώσουμε το αεπγιατί δε μεγαλώσει το αέδεν μπορούμε να συνεχίσουμε να έχουμε μια ισχυρι οικονομία
είναι και το τεράστε ο θέμα του εργατικού δυναμικού ου είναι μια μεγάλη πρόκληση γιατί
α θα μεγαλώσει το αέπχρειάζονται περισσότερα εργατικά χέρια σε όλα τα επίπερα παλαιότερα μιλούμ μιλούσαμε
μόνο για τους χαμηλόμιστους για τις δουλειές που δεν θέλουν να κάνουν κύπριή όμως αυτή
τη στιγμή και έλόγο της τεχνολογής αναβάθμησης χρειάζονται και περιστότερα μιαλά και ξέρω ότι γίνονται
προσπάθειες και από την κυβέρνηση για να επαναπατριστούν κάποια άτομα που ζούστο εξω το ετικό
όμως χρειάζεται και ένας μακροπρόθεσμο σκεδιασμός που είναι θα έλεγα το μεγαλήλο πρόβλημα της κύπρού
έχουμε το ώραμα ικό ιτριν ανταβέντε εκεί ελπίζω να να τηηρηθεί γιατί κάθε φορά που
αλλάζει κυβέρνηση ή έχουμε εκλωγές κάπου ξεχνάμε το μακρο πρόθεσό σχεδιασμό γιατί αν δεν έχουμε
ένα ξεκαάθαρο ώραμα για όλη την κύπρο ναιμεν θα υπάρχουν οι έκτακτες καταστάσεις και βεβαίως
πρέπει να διαχειρίζεσαι τα πράματα όπως ε έρχονται αλλά τουλάχιστο να υπάρχει μια συνέπια γιατο
που θέλουμε να πάμε και κλίνουμε ι αγκοπρόκλησης το επόγνο διάστημα σεακαι εικονομία